hey accidents happen but if you're in a
movie sometimes accidents can turn out
to be amazing in fact some of the most
memorable moments in cinema were
actually the result of mistakes that the
filmmakers decided were too good to
leave out of the finished movie here's a
look at some movie bloopers that were
too good to cut guardians of the galaxy
Alfred Hitchcock coined the term
MacGuffin to describe important objects
upon which the plot of a movie revolves
like the briefcase in Pulp Fiction or
the Infinity stones in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe as any comic fan will
tell you the Infinity stones are
incredibly important and powerful which
is why it's so funny when Chris Pratt as
star-lord just straight-up drops one let
us see what you brought
[Music]
it looks totally scripted but according
to the DVD commentary that was an actual
moment of clumsiness from Pratt but the
moment works so director James Gunn left
it in the Lord of the Rings two towers
there's war looms and the loss of Rohan
seems imminent Iowan stares off into the
distance as the camera reveals a wide
scenic shot as she does a flagpole whips
in the wind and then perfectly
expressing the mood of uncertainty and
destruction to come the flag rips off
the pole and flies away the metaphor was
not only beautifully apt but it was also
totally accidental director Peter
Jackson didn't plan for this it was just
really windy on that day of shooting The
Princess Diaries this movie made Anne
Hathaway a star and the DVD has become a
slumber party classic for little kids
it's a classic Ugly Duckling story of a
girl named Mia who finds out she's the
heir apparent to a small European
Kingdom but she's so very awkward you
see falling down all the time as she
learns how to carry herself with the
grace and poise befitting a royal at one
point Mia is dancing on some bleachers
in the rain at a private school with a
best friend when she takes a pretty
nasty tumble that's no stunt woman and
that wasn't supposed to happen
after wave really did slip falling hard
but it fit in so well with the
characters awkwardness that it was kept
in the finish film Casino Royale the
idea was simple Bond girl
rides a horse along the beach and Daniel
Craig swims up to her but as he floated
up the actor ran into a sand bank giving
him no choice but to quickly stand up on
his feet and stomp out of the water
suddenly bond is standing there muscled
up body on display along with some very
revealing swim trunks Casino Royale was
a reboot of the Bond series
so most fans assumed this was an homage
to the classic scene from the first Bond
film dr. know where Ursula Andress
emerges from the ocean but it was
actually just a lucky
Raiders of the Lost Ark Indiana Jones
wasn't the only Raider of the Lost Ark
in the Raiders of the Lost Ark there was
also evil French archaeologist Rene
Belloc who suffers a doubly horrible
fate
not only does his head explode
but he also needs a fly well okay not
exactly during a close-up of actor Paul
Freeman a fly appears to crawl right
down Belloc's throat Freeman later
revealed that the insect actually flew
away after crawling around his lip for a
moment but some judicious editing after
the fact but it looked like the
cold-blooded bellick just ate the fly
instead the usual suspects the police
lineup scene early in the movie is
crucial to the plot of the usual
suspects it's where all the criminal
main characters meet to arrange a big
heist as each character steps forward to
read the line police told them to read
none of them can contain their laughter
perfectly setting up the dynamic between
the characters as well as their
collective disregard for the cops
but The Laughing wasn't in the script
and it wasn't a directorial Note no the
cast of the usual suspects couldn't stop
laughing because actor Benicio del Toro
couldn't stop fighting co-star kevin
pollak says he farted on like 12 takes
in a row the director Bryan Singer got
so mad with the cast's inability to
focus that he yelled at them which
probably only made them laugh harder
Rain Man speaking of farts Rain Man is
that rare film that won the Oscar for
Best Picture and also included one of
the most memorable fight scenes in movie
history
brothers Raymond and Charlie are in a
phone booth together and Raymond passes
gas how can you stand there I don't mind
that was real and accidental stars
Dustin Hoffman and Tom Cruise both
managed to stay completely in character
setting up a classic moment in cinematic
fart history thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]